We got to know that this person was not aligned as per the scale requirement. So any gaps that you observed and what else we can look for in the individual that we want to present in the near future.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Okay, do you have the job description in your site? Can you share the job description?
Yeah, we do. We do.
Yep, we can send. Give me a sec.
In the screen.
Just to share it here.
Give me a second, let me pull this up.
Hello, Daddy.
As you can continue the conversation, I'm just grabbing it.
Yeah, yeah.
Yep, sure, sure, I'll do that. OK, so this this new guy, Jimmy, how is he settling it? I know he's going through the training, so...
Yeah, still he's in training and yeah, we need more time to somehow consider everything about him. So, and put everything together. But in training mode, typically people are good, we will...
thinking, learning, and say, okay, how everything is good, but in practice we should see.
So yeah, I think what I have observed about Jimmy is that he is spending most of the time, you know, shadowing the individuals who are assisting him with the ticket management, the process, IT glue and how to create the ticket and
Okay.
You know, other things as well, so he shares this report with me every day, so I go through it, whatever he has learned in that day. So, on the basis of that, I think he's doing a...
Mhm.
Good job there and eventually it would be a value addition to your team.
Yeah, we hope we hope that we can train him about whatever we want. And yeah, I think less than a month we can say, okay, we started the first or the first group of the tickets based on our requirement and then we can find like.
OK.
More information about.
All right.
For now, for now, he's asking all the right questions, at least in training sessions with me. He is taking good notes for what I can see. He should be starting on light tickets next week. It's going to be his two weeks. And then the week after that should be starting on phone calls as well.
Mhm.
So like Reza said, it's going to be a process where we monitor how he's doing, we slowly and carefully and methodically get him up to where he needs to be, and then we'll monitor from there.
I.
Great, thank you, Gadi. When you said that you would start with easy tickets, I presume it's for group E or D.
CGE, yes, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
OK, whenever you ready, I meet you can share a job description if you have it.
All right, then.
Yeah, just opening it.
We interact with Karin too much, so I have loads of loads of data coming up on my screen, so I believe this is the one. So, all right, I'm gonna share my screen.
And the reason we asked that question, Reza, is because we currently, you know, actively interviewing a lot of candidates. Let me know once you see my screen. Do you want me to increase this font size, maybe?
Mhm.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's not better.
Okay, cool.
Okay.
Okay, let's go one by one of the requirements here, if you agree.
Mhm.
Sure.
Go a little bit up, please.
Yeah.
One of the things that we mentioned here is about ability to help user install configuring smartphone iOS and Android. I don't see any related experience or skill in his resume.
Mm.
Yeah.
Another one is about Mac devices. Again, I don't see it in his resume.
Mhm.
Strong knowledge of on-premise Active Directory. There is an Azure Active Directory management, but nothing about on-premise Active Directory.
Uh, yeah, and uh...
Yeah, we we we need the cloud administration, SharePoint, Teams, OneDrive, Business, Remote Desktop, this kind of stuff. So, when you go to the resume, I see only VPN support, desktop connectivity, troubleshoot.
Art.
So he mentioned something, they mentioned something about MS Office and application support, but it's not clear for me that MS Office is a local MS Office, it's a user side MS Office or it's an administration.
Okay.
Because we have another row here, it says in deep knowledge of Microsoft Office applications. I just consider that Microsoft Office application that we mentioned here is the exact thing that they mentioned in their resume. Strong knowledge of Windows Server.
Butter.
OK.
and associated service such as DNS, DHCP, print file services. Nothing in his resume about that.
And yeah, if I want to go one by one of those, I found a lot, but it's clear that first we need to match things because you know, I don't want to waste their time and your time to be in a meeting with them, review all the skill set and then.
No, I think we, yeah, no, we're good.
Mhm.
Got it.
back and say, okay, yeah, wasn't enough because you know, it has a kind of like impact on their mind if they fail in the interview. So the best way is just compare everything based on what exactly we wanted. And then we say, okay, this candidate.
should be good on paper. And the next part is, okay, let's go for an interview, ask some detailed question related to these skills. And once we make sure we say, okay, go ahead, this is a good one.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Yeah, no, completely aligned. It just that, you know, we are interviewing quite a few candidates. So Ashish is also interviewing quite a few candidates we have in the pipeline. So we wanted to make sure that out of the skill set that we currently have on screen, right, if there is anything which is kind of a must have.
Mm.
Okay.
because when you have people coming in, right, you may have varied experiences. Somebody who is really good at old 365, right, troubleshooting, et cetera, but they probably will not have very good when it comes to backup, networking, so on and so forth. So, and ConnectWise is something that we can train internally.
Oh.
And.
Mm.
Yeah.
majority of the enterprise engineers that he come across, they will not have ConnectWise experience. So that's something that we can take care of. But again, it was, I wanted to take an opportunity to understand if there is something on this JD, which is non-negotiable, right, that without.
Mm.
Yeah.
Yeah, without that, you're not going to consider any engineer for the interview.
Yeah, yeah, it's a good question. The things that we mentioned, strong, it's not negotiable for us. When we say strong knowledge of this, means it's necessary, it's required. It's not nice to have. But when we say experience with ticketing system,
OK.
ConnectWise is an asset means ConnectWise is nice to have, but if they know how to work with Zendesk, it's okay. If they know how to work with any ticketing system, the concept is enough for us. We're going to train them. Yeah, but when we say like in deep knowledge of...
Mm.
Understood.
Microsoft application means really we need in deep or and with a strong knowledge of Windows Server should be really strong.
Mm-hmm.
Understood.
Yeah.
Got it. Thank you. Ashish, do you have any questions? Oh, good.
Nope, don't have any other questions.
All right, thank you, Reza, for the clarity. Appreciate it.
Yep.
Back to you.
Thank you.
All right, so, Riza.
You're muted, Arkady.
Sorry, sorry, if I may, one of the things they should be comfortable with, again, as we emphasized in previous meetings, is taking phone calls from an incoming queue that drinks or the help desk, right? There should be no hesitancy in picking up those phone calls and treating those as high priority. That is.
Yep, yep.
Yes.
Mm-hmm.
100%.
That is, that is also really not negotiable, not not negotiable.
Hundred percent, so there is a standard expectation that we have anybody that we interview. There are two things which are which we are really specific about is 1 flexibility to learn and work on multiple technologies because we are an MSP, so we cannot have people focused on just one side of the technology. And second is...
You.
flexible enough to go and take calls as per the requirement and as per the structure. So anybody that we're sending across, it a must have requirement before we even select them for the position.
Excellent. Thank you.
Thank you.
Yep.
Thank you so much, Akali, for sharing that. All right, so since we have this call now in a weekly cadence, this is specifically to focus on the progress of Bunch and things with JASP. So wanted to know how have you noticed them improving?
since our previous connect. If you noticed anything of that sort, please share and let us know where else we need to work on.
Yeah, I think having a weekly meeting, weekly meeting about the improvement and something like that, it would be it would be good, but we shouldn't expect a lot of improvement during the week. It's just, it's a process and the process needs.
time to somehow evaluate and assess the improvement. But the trend to me, the trend is good for Jasp. The trend for Jasp is good for Ranch. I would say it's very much.
slower than Jas, but it's okay. We can slowly back on the track. We need more time. I would say at least we need more two weeks to see comprehensive like improvement in their site.
Yeah, I mean, I don't need a decision that you that you believe that he has he has reached there. I only want you to know how you see the trend, if it is trending upwards, straight line or downward. This is what I wanted to know.
Mm.
I would say it's on track.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
It sounds right.
I think anecdotally, from my perspective, I've seen less questions. It seems like he's grasping a lot of the concepts with how we handle tickets. So when he's doing triage, he's not asking so much as, is this spam or is this, you know, urgent? He's starting to develop the abilities to kind of parse through those tickets and make those decisions on his own, which is
Sh.
Very encouraging.
Agreed. Yes.
Thank you.
Yep, and...
Arcadi, do you have any insight about this?
The.
Yeah, I'm observing the same thing, Toranes. A lot less questions about things that should be obvious, a lot better judgment, exercising judgment than before. It's not perfect by any means, but it's trending in the right direction. Yes.
Right, so the role shift that we did regarding the triage focus role that we worked on from a couple of weeks, I think that is this is now resulting because engineers are now getting more insight of the clients, their processes, and how they work on things. This is helping them in.
decision making rather than reaching out to teams and asking questions that they used to do in the past.
Yes, but they still do reach out for questions, as it's expected. It's not about whether they reach out at all. It's about the volume of questions and about the nature of the question itself. What are they asking? How are they presenting the question? How are they presenting the issue to us, right? All of that matters in terms of efficiency of time.
Mhm.
It.
So that, like I said, that is getting better. Fewer questions that shouldn't be questions, better context presented for the questions that are being asked. So as I said, it's trending upward, but we are not there yet.
I.
Yeah, and in additional note, I would say there are two different methods of asking questions. If I'm A technician, I can reach to my team leader, say, hi, my team leader, I got an urgent ticket from client and they have issue.
To act to access to like the remote desktop, this is this is one of this is the one method to ask a question, which means I'm gonna pass this responsibility to my team leader to go ahead and review everything and figure out what what exactly happened.
and then prepare a kind of like guideline for me. This is one way. Another way is I would say I got a ticket from client, they have issue to connect to RDS, I double check this and that, their topology is the same as this, they have to connect to this address, I ping this address.
I'm not able to connect to that address and it's now the decision point. What should I do for that? Means I have done my investigation. I tried my best. I couldn't find the workaround or solution. This is the best way to ask a question, but
If you only ask a question without giving your team leader any other information or without giving your team members any other information, it means always I need someone to help me to understand the ticket, do some initial...
steps, find a way and then let me know to how to fix the issue.
And we, and we expect, and we expect our technician to do the second part, which means do their investigation, try their best based on our timeline, based on their knowledge, and then reach to us.
The.
Yep, I completely get it.
Thank you. Any other questions or suggestions, Reza?
Or no, no, nothing from my end.
Thank you, Akali. Anything from your side?
Yeah.
Not for now.
Yeah, Jordan.
Yep, all good for me.
All right, with that being said, I'll quickly go ahead and share my screen and collectively go through the presentation deck.
Let me know if it's visible to you.
Yeah, it is.
Thank you. This is our weekly business review. Review duration is April 13th until 17th. Starting with our agenda items, which remains the same. We have check-in, highlights on the account, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of the customer, way forward, and then recap.
So we have already discussed this. How are things at this moment? I can skip this slide.
These were the discussion points from a previous Connect where we noticed improvement with JASP and a few things that needs to work on with Bench. We also discussed about the time that we have been given to work.
with Benj for the two weeks to make a decision whether he is aligned with the expectations or that's something that we have to replace him with another individual. So this is something that we're working on and things are looking stable as of now.
In terms of the plan that we have designed for the engineers that they're working on, triage focused role. So this is helping engineers getting knowledge about the clients. They were working on client C, D, and E, but I think on the basis of the instance that had happened with
the text prep ticket where they worked on few tickets from Group B and from Group A clients. So this had helped them in the previous week.
And we also agreed of moving the service call cadence from bi-weekly to weekly. So this is something that we have done already.
Any questions, Steve?
No, now those are clear.
Two.
This is the action tracker where 30, 60, 90 days plan is still awaited. I mean, Jas and Bunch have already spent 90 days, so it is now applicable to Jimmy, who just started a week ago. So, Reza.
When can we expect this plan for Jimmy?
Okay, can you export the training plan that we have for them? I mean, in our calendar, like say in this day, they're going to do this, in this week, they're going to do these kind of like stop. And then we can have a kind of like export of that.
Mmh.
Uh, calendar and send to them.
Sounds good.
We can review together before.
Okay.
Yep, that'll be helpful.
All right, second is reports to be scheduled for the KPI track. So this I have started receiving from this week. Earlier, I've been getting reports only for Jasp. Bansh's name was missing from it. So it has started coming from this Monday where I have both Jasp and Bansh added to the report. So I would have their
Data fetch from there and will present you in the upcoming the next.
Yeah.
Third is align call handling priority. So this I have discussed with both engineers and I think they are aligned in terms of handling the calls. So just wanted to know your perspective, Brza. How do you see it?
Call handling priority. It would be a question for Arkadi because he directly involved involved.
Yeah, it has been coming up in the multiple calls that any engineer who joins the team answering the calls has to be a priority. So this was cascaded to the team and they have already aligned. So I just wanted to know, have you noticed it?
Jasper has never been an issue on the phone calls and Vanj is improving, but he's not quite there in terms of the comfort with taking phone calls.
There should be an initiative to take the phone call without being asked to do so. That is my expectation from anyone who joins from ITPD, that they will take the initiative to pick up the phone calls without me having to go and ask them directly to do that.
Jasper is mostly great than that. Bench needs more work there.
So, when you said you have to reach out to to ask him to answer the phone calls, is it like the call is ringing at every extension at the same time and the person who is available answers the call? Or is it following the round-robin method? Okay.
It does, yes. No, no, there is no round robin. It, it, it, the phone call comes into everybody and rings for everybody who is signed into the queue, myself included. So, if nobody picks up, the phone keeps ringing and it keeps ringing and it keeps ringing, so...
The expectation is that the phone will call the phone call will be answered under 2 minutes. If it hasn't been answered under 2 minutes, then we have to go and ask technicians to pick up the phone call, right? So my expectation is that somebody who sees that the phone call has already been ringing for a while.
Yes.
Yeah.
will take the initiative to answer that phone call on their own without being asked to do so.
Yeah, and it's a matter of it's a matter of manage their time and manage their priority. Like, say, if if you're working on a ticket in one hand and in other hand you see an incoming call in three six.
Agreed.
should make your decision which one is the first priority. Working on your ticket is priority means you are working with a VIP user, you remote it to their computers, and they expected you to right away.
call them or fix the issue, or you have a call which is priority. Most of the time I would say we have less priority ticket in our site than phone calls. We do have...
What?
priority ticket like the tickets that we have with our VIP users or maybe if you pre-planned an orientation meeting or onboarding with the user you cannot be there you cannot answer the phone calls you already scheduled yourself for that user so.
Yes.
At.
We put this type of decision making on our technicians. Say, okay, think about your priority, make the decision about that. But at the end, if no one pick up the phone and answer the call, team leader has to go and ask them.
OK.
I got it. So I...
Yep.
There is just one thing. I'm sorry, Ashish, complete your thoughts.
Yes.
Thank you. So, I have one request from your card. If you can, I think it would be a bit for you. If you could please pull out the data for last week for Jasp and Vansh, like the number of calls that they have answered, because I when I when I when I discussed this with...
Yeah.
that and genius, I don't want them to give me that I start 4 hours late then just and by the time I log in, I don't get enough calls to answer. So I should have enough data to support when I do this conversation with the genius.
And.
Yeah, per day, calls per day average. I understand.
Yeah.
Yeah, always we have enough call to answer. They shouldn't worry about that.
Yes, yeah, that's right.
Yep, yep.
And Reza, just a follow-up question that I had, right? Do we currently have any benchmark or let's say matrix for them to say this is the minimum number of calls that one, I'm looking at the volume of course, right? Like I said, there are enough calls.
If...
Thank you.
Just.
This is a minimum number of calls that one should answer, so that we start.
doing the comparison in terms of how the day has been and how the week has been and start focusing on the people who are not hitting that benchmark.
Uh, the thing is, uh...
There are a couple of items involving to answer the phone call or not for a technician. So we cannot have any specific number or minimum number for technicians because the workload that they have is totally different.
Okay.
And their workload is based on their experience, the severity of the ticket that they have in their side, the difficulty of the ticket, and complexity of ticket, and the group of clients. These are a lot of parameters involved.
Mm.
any technician during the day. So we have no minimum. And the reason why, the reason why we put that decision making on their side is the best one who can make that decision that I'm free to.
To to answer the call or not, it's them, it's not us, 'cause you know we have it, we have it like we have a senior technician in our side, they are good, like say they're good in answering the phone call, they are good to handling tickets, they are good to...
OK.
handle the orientation meeting, onboarding, working with group A client. But what happens is, might they grab two or three tickets per day only for onboarding? And it took all of the day time for them. In other hand, we have some technicians who
Mhm.
Grab more than 20 to maybe 30 tickets in a day because of the less complexity that those ticket has, as well as phone calls, as well as other stuff, so having it having a minimum number, it's not.
It's not accurate, and even it's not true, and it's not a true parameter for evaluating the technician, but to me, those guys are not working on Group A&B clients now; they have they have enough.
Mm.
time and they have less priority to get in their side than other technicians so they can grab more. They can grab more call.
Sure, got it.
Yep, comparatively, absolutely. Yep. And Arkadi, when you said that you reached out to Vansh asking him to answer this call, at that time he was not on any call and he was not working on any ticket either. That means he was free, he was letting go of this call, right?
Yeah.
The way it works is that I evaluate who can take a phone call when it's been ringing too long, and I then go to individual technicians and ask them, can you take this phone call or not? If they are providing with a valid excuse why they cannot, I move on to somebody else.
Oh, okay.
Or, I would...
In Vancha's case, he has so far provided me varied excuses for why he's not taking a phone call. For example, he's already on another urgent ticket, or he is occupied with some other task that requires his attention, right? But the idea is to...
Yes.
not be chasing people in the 1st place. The idea is to show initiative in taking the phone call, to decide by yourself that, hey, I understand that my priority is the phone call. I'm going to pause whatever I'm doing, and I'm going to pick up that phone call. Right? It's...
See.
Yeah.
Yep, I think this is a similar conversation we had in the previous connect where you said that engineer needs to have this mindset that whenever a call comes, they need to ensure that if I can sneak out some time for my current ticket, if possible, then I can answer this call, address a user, and then continue with my remaining work on this particular ticket, right?
Yes, exactly.
So yeah, I'm aligned and I, on the similar lines, I gave this message to the team and they said that they would work on it. But in order to give them a further drill down on this one, I need supporting data, which for which I'm dependent on you. So once I get that information, I will have a discussion with Jasper and Vaj together.
Mhm.
with the data so that they cannot deny and then I'll be in a better shape to give them the required feedback.
Yep. Thank you. Thank you, Rakari. Thank you, Reza. Thank you, Tori.
OK.
Yep.
Amesa, do you have any question on this?
No, absolutely clear. Thank you.
Thank you. I'll move on to the next slide. This is the KPIs that we agreed on. I will have the data now. I'll put them here and share it when I share this presentation deck.
Move on to performance analysis real quick. This is the performance spotlight for Bunch. So this is on the basis of the board reviews that I do. And I'll start with the CSAT service that we have received for Bunch. This I got from the report that I received.
every Monday from Jeremy. So I have pulled this information from there regarding the CSAT service. So on the basis of my analysis, when she's working on triage, ownership, and handling tickets from group B, C, D, and E, along with some basic issues of group A,
And in terms of his follow-up, so I have gone through the ticket notes, the time that he put there that he would follow up with the user on this particular time and date. So I would see the relevant time entry against that day. So by this way, I was able to verify that he did follow up with the user on time.
which also verifies that his ticket hygiene is well maintained and notes our justifying the time that he was entering into the tickets. So, Gadi, your thoughts.
Yeah.
Yep, the survey is correct. The B&A is only as of yesterday, so that's too early to tell. Yes, generally the feedback from clients since their move to triage and BCD.
roles has been positive. I have also, yeah, I have noticed improved ticket hygiene and communication. Again, not just with the client, but also with the rest of the team and with me and Torrin and Reza.
Oh yeah, I would say customer satisfaction. We should not consider this part for them for now because they have less ticket with customers. So saying 100% positive server rating, it's not accurate because the dimension and the scope of.
Yeah.
Their ticket is not client face, so I think how we should we should consider it after we assign another ticket, real customer face ticket to them, then we can evaluate the customer satisfaction.
Yes.
Ohh.
And about the categories, the numbers that you mentioned here, 40 to 45% of contribution for triage, active user, this one and that one, I'm not sure where those numbers are coming from.
So these numbers came from the board reviews that we do for the engineers and we go through the technologies on which they are working on, which technology is involved on which ticket. So by that we bifurcate like, we segregate like which ticket belongs to which technology and basis of that I created this analysis.
Mhm.
Ohh.
Okay, can you confirm that Ranch worked on onboarding new hire tasks?
What are you?
Yeah, this doesn't make a lot of sense to me because, well, first of all, administrative work is a significant portion of their work as triage, right? Also, I am pretty sure the only new hires or onboarding tasks they do, actually, no, I shouldn't be doing any of them, like offboarding tasks.
Yep.
Yeah.
possibly as initial steps to then be reviewed by an SME. But do we have any ticket examples where he did onboarding work?
Yeah, we need more details. I think I think we need more details about that, because to me, maybe 50 to 60 of their 60% of their job would be administrative activity for now, because it's triaging, working on stuff. Might you might you have to mix triage and administrative work together?
I don't have the ticket standing. Yep, okay.
Yeah.
You?
And it does make sense after that. In terms of active user facing level one, level 2 support, which is 30 to 35, yeah, should be, maybe, but I don't understand the difference between active user facing level one, level 2 support with like...
Okay, yeah.
Education and Citrix RDS activities or access email.
Yeah, ideas activity, active email, because you know, when we somehow summarize all the numbers, we reach 200 person. So in this case, I think access email administrative requests and something like that would be a part of active user phrasing.
Maybe, yeah, I think you need to align these numbers and you need to have more details, share it with us, then we can help, yeah, we can help to somehow categorize the contribution.
Sure.
Additionally, all of our client communication falls under administrative work. So that will also be, in addition to triage, when they're communicating with clients on tickets, that will be also part of administrative work.
Mhm.
Okay, so this administrative piece is obviously non-billable time entry that they have made. So automatically that is taken as administrator because it is not billed to the partner. I just want a quick clarification on the survey piece that you mentioned. So this came from the report that I received.
Yeah.
Every Monday, so, so how would you, how would you say that? Is this report not from the users who rated the ticket work by Bunch or Jasp as positive, or is it something else?
I don't say that. I would say the number of tickets, because you can focus on something like say if they have 13 surveys for a week, means they handled 13 tickets in a week, which was client face. But if you back to our standard,
Just.
T.
You see every single technician handle like more than 10 to 12 or 15 tickets in a day. So the scope that you mentioned, 13, how yeah, can be can be correct, but it's not enough to consider 100% satisfaction.
Correct.
No, no.
The more tickets you handle, the more surveys you get, the more negative, neutral, and positive you get. So yeah, it's possible that I handled 2 tickets in a week and I got 100% of satisfaction on those.
Which is correct, but what is the scope?
And then, then a technician handle like 90 tickets in a week.
That's the point. So I would say, I don't want to say this number is incorrect. I would say considering customer satisfaction, considering customer satisfaction for now is not in place for the one who focused on triage.
Sample size is too less to make a deadline.
OK, got it.
Yeah.
Okay, I made a similar.
Slide for just Jazz as well.
So again, for him, he received 9 surveys. Again, on the similar lines, sample size is not enough to rate how satisfied of the customer. So I'll take it. In terms of the ticket ownership, so as you have already mentioned, Gary, that Jasper is on top of things.
Yeah.
He's proactive in terms of asking for the work in the tickets and handling all the incoming calls which are ringing on the extension. There is just one thing I wanted to get clarification on is waiting on customer one, waiting on customer 2 statuses of we have in the tickets.
So I know whenever a customer technician calls a user, if user is not available, they would email the user and leave the ticket. Third day, an automated email will send out to the user. And if the user is not responding, the ticket would change to VTC compliant too.
Am I right so far?
Yeah, after three days, it goes to waiting on client one. And then I think after an additional 3, it goes to waiting on client 2. But that's only if they have to set that response properly in the 1st place to waiting on client. And then it will cascade through that automation.
Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yep, yep. So, when that automated email goes to the users, I believe there is no entry in the same ticket that an automated email went out, unless we go to the workflow that the automated email was sent out. So, obviously, someone who is aware of the tool usage,
Ohh.
would know that he has to click on this option to verify if email was sent out or not. So, and I know after another third day, the email that can go to betting on client 2 or betting on client 3, until user is not available, then the ticket would be closed. So I'm just seeking your advice and just guide me if this can be done.
Can users email or call the user maybe on the second day? Because I just want to make sure that we don't have tickets waiting in the queue for more than seven, 8, or nine days without users responding and then eventually ticket is getting closed automatically.
Well, they shouldn't call them for follow-ups because the way our system works is we communicate through email first to arrange a time for a follow-up with their call or remote session if needed, right? So it would only be communication by email with the user, but this automated system exists precisely so that they don't have to do that.
Okay.
So, they shouldn't have to remember to do that, or...
so that we don't rely on them remembering to do that. That's why this automation was implemented. And this automation was agreed upon per our standards, so that if it ends up with a ticket waiting for a week, then that's the nature of the automation, right?
Okay.
Present.
Completely aligned. I just wanted to get clarification that if it happens, I know we would have tickets sitting for multiple days in the queue without any update. So it doesn't look nice, so I just wanted to put it up so that you are aware. That's it.
Okay.
It can happen, yes, yes.
Yeah, it can happen, but we have process, internal process for that. One of the things that Arcadia and Torian typically do is they review technicians queue and see what happened, which ticket is pending for client, which ticket is pending for us.
T.
and then make their decision to how to handle it, regardless of the automation process that we have for ConnectWise. So shouldn't be worried about that. Arcadian Turing can handle it in our side. Because when you use automation, automation doesn't consider the client sensitivity, the client.
Yeah.
expectations, might we have a contract with client, but there are side expectations from client and their contract. Like say we have a SLA with our client for tickets, and for tickets to the SLA is 4 hours fixing the issue for urgent stuff.
But in reality, when we have an urgent, we're going to address it in less than 20 minutes, and sometimes less than 10 minutes. So if we want to only rely on automation and say, okay, based on automation, we should wait for this and that to happen, it doesn't work.
It.
Mhm.
So I would say the source of truth to me in this kind of case to handle the proper workflow is Arkadian Tori.
They can outlet.
As I was just explaining to Jimmy yesterday in the training session, it's about making a judgment call. It's not, you don't always set it to waiting for client and you don't always follow up the next day. Sometimes the client says like, yeah, but we're good, close the ticket. And it's okay to just close it, right? And if the client says, you know, check with me tomorrow.
Yeah.
And.
this, then you will not rely on the information, you will check with them tomorrow. It's all about making judgment code in the context of the ticket or the situation as well, which is why that judgment ability is so important in the technician.
Correct.
Yep, so this is only applicable when user is not responding at all.
It's applicable to standard situations, right? When you're not immediately closing the ticket or following something, some other process that you agree to with the user or with the primary, for example, the approval for that company. If there may be something that the user wants, but an approval for the company wants something else entirely,
right, then you go what the approver wants, right? If let's say one of our biggest client approver says, hey, follow up with this user tomorrow, please, you follow up tomorrow, you won't wait for the automation to kick in and do it automatically for you, right?
Got it.
Guys, I have to jump on another meeting. Our meeting took more expected then. You guys can continue. You guys can continue if you need water.
Yep, I'm sorry, I did not realize the time. Yep, yep, I'm so sorry for that.
Yeah.
No, thank you, Reza. I think the reason we have so much questions is because, you know, we want to make sure that we're adding value on the ground. So if we understand better, we drive them better, right? So the idea is to, yeah, okay, so that is the intent. Thank you.
Yeah, yeah.
Totally, I agree.
So.
Totally agree, totally agree, totally agree, and we are here because at the end, Ashish, Amit, we are all a team. We are all a team. If we understand client requirement, if you're if you're if you understand our process better, definitely you can.
Absolutely.
S.
have a kind of like site training with your technician and we'll be there for all of us. Okay, thank you guys and have a good rest of your day. Bye.
Yes.
Sure, yeah.
Thank you.
Get on.
Thank you so much, everyone.
I.
Select.
Excellent.